how does it feel to have your name added
to the list of sophisticated Scorsese's
putting men it's very difficult to
process I don't I don't quite believe it
I'm gonna wake up at some point soon
very honored in the meantime before I
wake up I'll just be very grateful for
it and especially to work on this
project with him and I read that you
were silent for seven days while
preparing for this role
yeah that's right yeah yeah we did you
ever done a silent retreat no I saw the
crazy to me it's a ancient spiritual
practice it's like you know you tune
into yourself and you kind of you can
hear things clearer I know like them you
know I have like friends that still
sleep with a nightlight and still sleep
with like a slight you know the TV or
the hairdryer on their feet and it's
like what the hell like we're so used to
this and this noise this din is this
kind of comforting thing that I think
silence has become a very scary thing
but actually it is kind of scary but
there's a beautiful mystery in it as
well now did this this movie or this
role impact your belief system I've
always been a seeker of a spiritual life
I suppose
and I'm always kind of exploring things
but this was a really deep immersion
into obviously being a Jesuit which
there were aspects of it that I just
kind of fell it fell in love with that's
the question of how do you live a life
of faith how how are we supposed to live
in this chaos and this anarchy in this
nihilistic view of what it is to be
alive it's a very very interesting
question
[Music]
but get lost just bring her silence
[Music]
you